like i've actually worried a lot about
becoming too american and like not
staying in touch with my japanese roots
[Music]
happy new year everybody
is happy 2022
i am back with another vlog i guess wow
i really don't remember how to make
videos because it's been a while i went
totally offline for the most part for
the last two weeks of 2021 which was so
needed so good albeit it was forced
because i got covered in the last week
but i'm feeling much better our holiday
was really fun the first week we just
kind of hung out was winding down from
work we did a twitch stream on scott's
channel uh where we made latkes it was
really fun recordings and all of that
will come soon because we're gonna make
a family channel very soon and for
christmas my brother came and we just
kind of hung out it was very chill and
then a few days after christmas i got
covered so yeah that wasn't super fun
but very
lucky to have gone by with some very
mild symptoms i was boosted too yeah
we've been doing the 10 day quarantine
haven't been going anywhere been getting
grocery delivery and stuff kona is very
unhappy about that because he hasn't
been getting his walks you're just sad
that you haven't been able to go on dubs
huh i know i'm sorry but this year my
two things that i want to do for this
year number one is
basically means have flexibility in the
work that i do and have flexibility in
my life instead of maxing out to 100 and
everything that i do and maxing out my
time and energy maybe only work to 70 or
80 percent i think that is what will
probably hopefully enable creativity to
thrive it'll allow me to stay more
balanced in life it got to a point last
year where i was just like i i don't
have any time to do the dishes because i
have more work that's important i'm kind
of like if i don't even have time to do
dishes i'm probably working too much
just trying to have better balance so
that's number one the second one is to
have more fun in my work because
again i'm one of those people
in work that i'm just like i need
structure and i need plans and i need
growth which it's funny because that's
exactly how like a lot of tech companies
run that's one of the reasons why i left
tech and yet i find myself doing that
even though nobody's telling me to
because that's like just the pattern
that i'm so used to
and i'm like dude
i should have more fun in the work that
i do and not have it stress me out all
the freaking time because i am very
lucky to be able to do something that i
like doing so just have fun with it when
you go oh i also over break made some
updates number one got a haircut trying
out this whole
curtain bang situation with a middle
part i've also been doing my makeup
every day
because
after being sick and just being kind of
a slob for like a week i'm like i kind
of want to feel like i'm excited to be
awake today and why not
paint my face so that when i catch
my reflection in the mirror i'm like oh
girl you look good
as a way to give myself energy second
thing that i updated was my desk area
here's what my desk area looks like now
it was originally just completely blank
wall except for the clock right there
also i realized that i haven't actually
done like an office tour before i've
talked about different parts of my
office but
maybe it's worth doing a full office
tour of 2022 in the meantime just wanted
to show you all the things that i did i
put up
that floating shelf i've had that plant
for a very long time i put up these
sound panels i'm still
testing to see if it actually dampens
sound but i did want something behind my
monitor also the other thing too about
this whole setup is that it works both
in the sitting and the standing motion
so it's more flexible like that but it's
looking
a lot nicer so i'm pretty proud of that
other things i've been doing a lot over
break i've been playing a ton of animal
crossing and i've been watching a lot of
animal crossing videos
and i've been like scott i totally get
why you watch gaming videos now because
it's so fun to see other people play the
game that you like to play oh another
thing that i did over break was watch
kohaku
it's like this year-end
japanese
music
show it's like four or five hours long
it's hosted by
nhk who's basically like the bbc of
japan
i was watching it and i was like man i
used to like relish and look forward so
much to watching kohaku because it used
to be like my one glimpse into japanese
music i guess it's like a very good
summary of like
what is the hotness in japan right now
what's everyone else listening to and
especially when i was in high school and
i was like trying to plug into japanese
culture as much as possible i would
literally watch kohaku with a notepad
and pen and jot down all the songs and
artists that i like and then eventually
try to find their music online so it was
cool watching it i really enjoyed it and
i had a lot of fun i was like dancing
for the songs that i really liked
but it was a fun time i liked it a lot
[Music]
happy
monday everybody i don't know about you
will maybe there's some japanese
american audience people in out there
but like
at the end of the year especially during
new year's time i feel like i become
very japanese i think maybe it's because
new year's is actually like the biggest
holiday in japan there's like a lot of
tradition stuff wrapped up in in that
whole thing so like eating meat
eating mochi eating
a lot of food culture as well as like
wrapping up the new year kind of
festivities and like
traditions and then also traditions to
start the new year
it's one of the opportunities for me to
like really get in touch with my
japanese side all the music that i
listen to is japanese all the tv that i
watch is japanese i start reading a lot
of japanese like news and books and
manga and stuff i started watching a lot
more japanese youtube a lot of the food
i eat is japanese sometimes i'm almost
just like i'm basically in japan
not really not really i do the same
stuff as i would in japan i've noticed
it as a pattern for
years now at this point especially the
last two years having not gone on japan
i'm just like i'm
[Music]
hey for those of you who are like living
between two different countries or
cultures or whatever do you also have
times where like
you just like really tap into
one culture over the other at specific
times and seasons and stuff on the note
of cultural identity though i've always
wondered if i was just gonna become more
american than more japanese
or like one or the other as i grew up
and i'm realizing i'm like neither i'm
like becoming more american and more
japanese at the same time like i've
actually worried a lot about becoming
too american as i grew up and like not
staying in touch with my japanese roots
and then also seeing
people become really japanese and then
completely lose touch with their
american side which i also was like i
don't want that either so i feel like
i'm like threading the needle towards a
version of myself that
i've never seen
in other people before it's like i don't
know what the shape is going to be just
yet of who i am going to be
and i'm piecing it together little by
little in hopes that it's like a
gorgeous tapestry shape piece of work
art thing
growing up is a very interesting
let's see so at this point i wanted to
thank the sponsor of today's vlog
sakurako so sakurako which is this box
right here is a monthly japanese snack
subscription box where they send you 19
to 20 different like snacks and treats
and sweets and teas
right to your door along with one
additional like japanese wear i got the
february box in front of me i actually
already opened it so it's like not
nicely packaged or anything like that
but i wanted to show you inside comes
with a lot of like cultural notes about
japan about the theme for that month as
well as notes about all the different
snacks that are in there where it's from
the allergen information the flavors and
stuff which is really handy and i want
to show you my favorites in this month's
box because there are some things that
are like my absolute favorite snacks the
first of which is this eb mayo arare it
comes individually packaged because
japan it's like mayonnaise and shrimp
flavored it's not very shrimpy like not
too like fishy shrimpy but it's just got
like a really good mayo flavor and i
love japanese mayo and i love mayonnaise
cookies
the other thing that i really like
are these these are like uncle bom aku
him so basically it's like a cake
on the outside with red bean filling on
the inside the red beans really good
it's sweet but not cheesy and then the
cake on the outside is really nice and
moist this has also been one of my
favorite snacks too i mean
i just love red beans and i love cakes
so why not put the two together
and then this month's box or february's
box comes with a little plate now if you
want to create yourself a little like
snack plate
and then just like a cup of tea so
definitely worth it it's so nice that
they send something like this along with
the box so if you want this february box
then make sure to order before february
if you also want authentic japanese
snack sweets and treats and teas
delivered right to your door then make
sure to use the code tiger before
january 31st to get an extra home goodie
in your box everything about sakuraku is
linked in the description box down below
thank you so much for sponsoring this
video sakurako and uh i'm gonna get to
work because i am nice and fueled up by
these yummy yummy treats
[Music]
i'm just playing games
you
hey everybody happy
tuesday happy tuesday so i was thinking
about what i said yesterday while
filming about how i've been feeling very
japanese and i thought why not share all
the different things
that i think are so vital to my living
that happen to be japanese so i guess
we'll start with skincare stuff
generally skin care things i use
japanese products i think i have
japanese skin i like the way the
japanese skincare works in that it's a
lot about just like making your skin
very moisturized i use muji skincare
line this one's actually completely
empty this is the all-in-one gel i use
this all the time i've used it for many
years and then also spf too i've started
using this because
i'm turning 30 this year and your girl
needs to take care of her skin this is
the suncut uv perfect essence super
waterproof spf the other thing is
japanese cleansing things too so this is
the hadarabo
i've also used this for many many years
i just like the way that japanese like
skin care
like what is it japanese like
um sengang what is this face wash feels
because it gets very like bubbly and it
feels like it goes deep into my pores
other
kind of more medicinal things actually
you all use sarong this is like this is
an american thing too but it's by a
company called
so it's a japanese product i could not
live without these i have
such freaking
tense tight shoulders and neck and
anytime that it hurts too much i stuff
one of these on here it's basically like
a icy hot but it's just icy genuinely
can't live without these other japanese
products that i can't live without kaido
kaido i don't know what kaido means but
it's basically a hot pack you take it
out
and then it comes in this little thing
you take off the back thing it's an
adhesive and then you just i usually
just put it on my stomach i just stick
it on one of the things that i learned
from growing up japanese maybe this is a
generally asian thing but like
it's important to keep your stomach warm
because i notice that when my stomach is
really cold my stomach hurts
also this really helps her period pain
too i can't live without these either
this is one of those things that when i
became an adult and live by myself i
realized
my parents having this at all times
stocked in their house was something
that i also wanted to do so also for
these medicinal products i'm not a
doctor i'm not prescribing anything
these are things that work for my body
maybe not for you so all the disclaimer
next one is this one it's called
biopedum i like to call it s medicine
it's basically probiotics i want to say
i buy this in japan because it's hard to
actually find it in the states whenever
i have a stomachache indigestion
constipation
just not feeling too hot in the stomach
area i just eat three of these and this
is also one of those things that was
always stocked on my parents house and i
realized i needed to oh i did have one
more cosmetic item gatsby don't know
gatsby if you have asian hair you know
what gatsby is it's hair wax so it's
like
pretty
moussey it also smells really good yeah
so when i do my hair i curl it or i
style it or something hairspray
doesn't work my hair is so stubborn and
will not stay in any shape whatsoever
unless i put hair wax in it so usually
what i do is i take a little bit like a
dime size put it on my hands grow like
this and then i scrunch it like this i
scrunch it like that and then
it stays next one is this one babu or
just any bath salt in general is
basically like a little tablet it comes
in these like individual things this one
is usu scented
and then i pop it in my bath and it's
basically like a bath bomb but much
smaller i like these more than bath
bombs because i feel like japanese bath
salt things are a little bit more
medicinal maybe not like i mean they
they just like here it says like for
like shoulder pain for back pain for
like when your body is like too cold
when you if when you have chills it's
good for that and it does really help
like relax my body i guess now that i
think about a lot of the stuff with my
japanese a lot of my japanese products
are like relaxation related but yeah
those are all of like my favorite
japanese things curious what are some of
the things in your life that you've
involved from your own culture in your
day-to-day life that you just can't live
without so leave them in the comments
down below
i think right now i'm actually i think
i'm actually gonna do tea time
and then i have a meeting later and i'm
just gonna chill so that's the plan for
today